you said you don't actually type on the
computer you're not into the new
technology are you what kind of phone do
you have let you have a self what kind
of what are you doing even though I'm on
the internet I have a lot of flip phones
anymore one know the best thing about it
yes it's a phone okay you can talk into
it
I don't I don't text now I receive text
burner on send text right I like I
missed the remember the phone we put the
finger in her and no Larry I don't I
like I had the push-button phone but I
didn't you you had the I remember the
party line give me Wrigley five two five
see
you ever have the candlestick no that's
way before I appreciate I appreciate
everything modern I understand
technology I know that the world is
changing but there's a part of me that
wants to say slow down
yes slow down let's have a let's take a
breath all advances have detractions
there are a lot of great things about
Twitter there are bad things you can
send a rumor around the world yes you
could hurt people yes I don't like that
yeah
well so you probably had this experience
when you like these days there's no such
thing as just going into a room and you
turn on the lights
there's the helis my advice is Mort I
got a house I got a house in Beverly
Hills it's another one of my wife's
great dreams this was a turnkey house no
you just got to move in you just bring a
toothbrush you don't have toilet first
her second day would air she says to me
you like this carpeting yeah well I
liked it you don't like it right they
come with a piano move a guy comes this
is a piano mover I said we don't have a
piano now you do right I think that's
okay so this house is all computerized
the lights connected a TV connectedness
and when they go bad everybody goes bad
right I'm sitting in the bathroom the
lights go out because you're crazy so
the guy comes as they're called geeks
they're all like 26 years old and they
repair computers and this guy's in the
house and he's working on all the things
and I said to him hey there's a new
thing at the hardware store you're not
gonna believe this course 29 cents it's
a switch and up the light goes on and
this genius geek system II went what do
they call it
where did you get all my tweets I like
this it's strange but I just thought
about my tricycle alright I like I'm
saying I like these you could do anyone
can do them yeah Amy give me a thought
every thought in your mind one sentence
as the peanuts have to have salt on them
okay
give me a thought gum disease isn't
funny those reports yeah geez isn't
funny peanuts have to have salt right
I like walnuts ooh be use yours yours
are the best I like the smell of
turpentine are you a basement smelling
turpentine I have try like the smell of
turpentine I like this one
bring back the miniskirt wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]